let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
monday
we have to figure out
is he endorsing jd mandel or josh vance
in ohio and the other question the other
question we have to ask ourselves the
other question that is very important
this morning is did space force
find the planet nars
did they i don't know did they find the
planet nars that i'm dead serious folks
this is the [ __ ] we got to contend with
this morning
after the nazi rally in nebras excuse me
the trump
q and on rally
in nebraska
it's a q anon rally it's a [ __ ] cult
have you seen some of the videos
that have come from this rally these
people are absolutely batshit crazy they
have lost
their god damn minds
and i said this last week and really the
week before
the more we watch video from these from
these rallies he's queuing on rallies
the more i believe that
the reason why his supporters seem to
get dumber and dumber and dumber it's
because a lot of people are peeling off
from this [ __ ] chest absolute
delusion delusional garbage
i mean even trump is peeling away from
it he doesn't even know who he's
endorsing at this point in key senate
races listen
the only way
that the republicans make sure to hold
the senate
is to win the race in ohio
like that is one of that
pennsylvania florida those are some of
the
georgia those are some of the most
important races for mitch mcconnell
to become the minority majority leader
and take chuck schumer's position in the
senate to take control the senate
that way there's no confirmations they
lock up everything they obstruct
everything joe biden and the democrats
can't do [ __ ] that's their plan
that's the plan
think about it
the guy who's supposed to deliver the
republican party the victories in these
races donald trump their leader their
lord their god their republican jesus
the mango mussolini jesus grandpa poopy
pants the cheeto dust mobster is
supposed to deliver them these victories
and by delivering them victories he's
supposed to endorse the candidate who
can win in the general midterm in the
primary
the [ __ ] can't even remember his
goddamn name
a lot of people that the dementia don is
is traveling around
twitter i don't i i actually do not
believe this is a mental incapacity on
trump's behalf
i am i am for sure 100 for sure that
trump does not give a [ __ ] about people
in ohio does not give two [ __ ] not one
not two no [ __ ] to give for anyone in
ohio including
josh mandel and jd vance doesn't give a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the only thing trump cares about at this
point
is to have his little q anon gatherings
so they'll [ __ ] fill his coffers for
the next week
i mean he's paying 10 grand a [ __ ]
day we found that out 10 grand a day and
ain't just weekdays it ain't business
days folks it's a [ __ ] day 10 grand a
day boom boom boom he's racking up the
bills
which is only a step further and closer
to criminal contempt in new york we find
out this morning that georgia
georgia
has convened a criminal grand jury
and what and what
apparently what we all know is crime
we've listened to the [ __ ] tapes we
know what he was trying to do down in
georgia he was trying to get rather
burger to [ __ ] commit election fraud
so that way he could take over the
country and be the dictator the king
because there's no other way that this
guy wins besides cheating
so i am not surprised that he doesn't
give a [ __ ] who the candidate is in ohio
nor who he endorses i mean jesus christ
he he flew all the way to nebraska to
endure herbster or some [ __ ] like that
a roy moore wannabe
that's what it looks like to me he's roy
moore's doppelganger this [ __ ]
herbster or whatever and apparently he's
a [ __ ] kid diddler not surprising
with the gqp that he's a [ __ ] grabber
not at all
and it's not surprising that a [ __ ]
grabber would fly all the way from
mar-a-lago to nebraska to endorse
another one not surprising
at all
at a q anon rally
you know where they can grift
griff the queuing on
and really fill his coffers for the next
week that's why they're having these
rallies every goddamn weekend
every [ __ ] weekend they're having
these rallies
because he's burning through cash like
quickly
josh
josh vance and jd mandel holy [ __ ]
you you just you can't even you can't
even make this [ __ ] up
you can't you can't
he turns and we're gonna watch the video
probably a couple times here
he turns to ask someone what the what
the motherfucker's name is
is it jp oh no no jd jd mandel that's
what he said that's the [ __ ] quote
it ain't because he has dementia folks i
mean he may be [ __ ] he may be off his
rocker he may be you know losing his
his marbles
i think his marbles packed up and left a
long time ago they're like let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
let's get the [ __ ] out of here this is
crazy let's go live with jd mandel and
josh vance
oh my god
this guy does not know who the candidate
is in ohio and he doesn't give a [ __ ] he
doesn't care because he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about people in ohio he could care
less
and really people in ohio the people who
support trump or whatever the [ __ ] they
do
bow down to the religion of q anon
whatever the hell they're doing i don't
know
it's really [ __ ] weird and confusing
at this point
whatever they're doing they should know
that that is a signal that he does not
give two shits about them he can't even
remember what candidate they're supposed
to vote for
that he endorsed holy actual [ __ ]
there's a lot more news today than just
just this
this jd mandel fiasco and and the nars
did you hear he wants to go to nars
the planet nars
i don't know
i i don't know
it's a lot of news this morning uh
fulton county seems to be convening a
grand jury that is looking into the
possible crimes
possible my ass we know the crimes we've
seen that we've heard the tapes
into the election crimes that
donald trump and his minions tried to
crime in georgia
looks like there's a grand criminal
grand jury uh mark esper has a book out
of course i don't know if you know who
mark esper is he's a trumper
dementia don's running around hashtag
defends
uh dims defend democracy
and hashtag weird
gop is
is trending also adam kinzinger but i'm
telling you i got a ton of footage a ton
of video to go through today i mean just
a stack load we probably won't get to
all the [ __ ] video
that's how [ __ ] bad it is
there's just so many [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
out there
that are willing to get front of a
microphone and say some crazy ass [ __ ]
crazy ass cueing on [ __ ]
we're gonna try to
sift through some of this video
these people are from planet nars
apparently holy [ __ ] i think gabe
sanchez is going to join us today our
co-host and executive producer
looks like he's going to be joining us
here in about oh five or ten minutes
maybe at the bottom of the hour
whoosh
it's crazy
i want to welcome everyone to the show
thank you for being here
thank you
for being here
on this monday morning
we have who do we have in the chat holy
moly we got so many people
you guys know we broadcast live every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch and now
from the midas touch facebook page
ferret's here caitlin's here debbie from
salt lake is here amanda hello amanda
good morning
uh reuben from facebook anita from
facebook todd uh matt
patricia there's so many from facebook
here all you new facebook listeners
listen up if you are on the face face of
books or the books of face or whatever
you're doing over there on the meta
universe at the top of this broadcast
there is a link there
for the youtube channel hit that and
subscribe to our youtube channel you do
not want to miss a thing
not a thing do you want to miss all the
videos of their clips are on our youtube
channel
make sure to go subscribe the link is
right there at the top of the post on
facebook
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel channel so you don't miss a
thing
i mean again we broadcast live every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
and now from the midas touch facebook
page but you don't want to miss anything
if you want to see our tweets go at tony
michael's pod over on the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends and you will find
our tweets
and you know if you like the video
that's fine but a lot of people like to
listen just do you want to hear my
beautiful cathartic voice go download
every single episode
on google spotify apple
and leave a good review while you're
there
and i don't know if you guys notice this
the audience out there who downloads
there's a lot of you who download the
podcast to just listen to it not just
watch it but if you're downloading it on
the directories you noticed
that we put the best of the week on
there this weekend and we also put
bonehead of the week the last couple
weeks so now you will be able to
download the tony michaels podcast seven
days a week not just the live episodes
but the best of
every single saturday and the bonehead
of the week
speaking of that don't forget
to stay tuned and vote every single week
for bonehead of the week
just follow tony michael's pod to do
that
and then on fridays here's what happens
for all the new listeners on thursdays
we put out the bonehead of the week poll
you vote
you decide who the bonehead of the week
is
and then on friday in the second hour of
the show because we do two hours every
single weekday live
in the second hour we break down your
vote for bonehead of the week and that's
most important we're practicing
democracy here
we're practicing and we're going to get
to some of that news about our democracy
soon today and this morning
so stick with us here
stick with us today we're going to go
through a ton of video a ton of reaction
oh on a bunch of q anon maga rally trump
nazi q anon gathering i don't know what
the hell these things are anymore it's
really confusing it's confusing the [ __ ]
out of me i don't know if they're i mean
it's a [ __ ] cult
it's a cult let's just call it what it
is it's a goddamn cult
hmm well let's do this
since we have so much video and so much
footage to get to let's go ahead and go
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast where we round up all
the tweety tweets and trendy trends on
the [ __ ] list roundup we have reached
that part of the show where we round up
all your favorite 3d tweets and trendy
trends of the day
here's the issue
we have a lot a lot of [ __ ] to get to on
this list
i mean there's just
it never ends with these folks so let's
go to the timeline here now let's get to
some video
well of course let's start with the nars
video let me make this a little bigger
so you guys can see this [ __ ]
bonehead um i said
i said how much how much did we spend
for space force to find nars
again he's standing on stage and he's
giving a speech
i mean
whatever the hell that means
he's yelling conspiracy theories into a
microphone at best but let's listen to
what planet he thinks we're gonna go
land on we'll land the first woman on
the moon and the united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on
ours
on nars
we will land the woman on the
river
[Music]
you need to lay off the adderall there
grandpa
jesus [ __ ] christ are you kidding me
whoosh nars
[Music]
i can't even it's i mean we're not we're
past satire at this point
this is [ __ ] you can't even [ __ ]
write you can't write this [ __ ] you
can't and and this this isn't the
[ __ ] the beauty the gem of how dumb
this [ __ ] is this weekend
and and the people behind him don't even
get it they don't even get it like he's
just there reading off this [ __ ]
crazy ass [ __ ] just so you'll give him
the money for the next week i mean he's
just going week by week you know most
americans live paycheck by paycheck this
guy's living griff by grift
i mean he has been for his almost his
entire entire adult life that's why
russia has it in for him i mean god damn
they've been
they they've been fueling this [ __ ]
his money laundering machine for decades
and now now he can't rely on vladimir
putin anymore because it looks like
vladimir putin may end up eating an ammo
sandwich soon
so
well you know that's what happens to
murderous dictators that try to take
over sovereign nations in our modern
world they end up eating an ammo
sandwich in a bunker somewhere i'm just
saying
you're saying or they are they become
rope testers i i'm you know epstein
didn't chit
that's how it works
in our modern society we just don't put
up with murderous dictators committing
war crimes eventually they topple
yup
but this guy thinks we're gonna land on
nars
now obviously obviously he's trying to
save mars
but he's had a little too much adderall
i'm guessing
i'm guessing he's had just a little bit
too much adderall
let's go back to some more clips it gets
better we're gonna have to move quickly
here i'm sorry if we're moving fast
through this commentary but jesus christ
we got we just got so much goddamn [ __ ]
to get to today
no because of this trump rally and not
only that we have some trevor noah and
the white house correspondents dinner
footage that we want to get to as well
there's just so much [ __ ] to talk about
speaking of uh [ __ ] to talk about uh
gabe do you get your microphone on it's
working oh okay okay good good good good
good i see you're uh what are you
covering uh burns aren't real
well i did tweet the birds aren't real
do you want to watch this video we'll
watch this video we've got a live show
yeah i've watched uh well i i've watched
all the videos from the 60 minutes
we got to get this kid on the show this
is [ __ ] hilarious i don't know if you
guys if you guys don't know what birds
aren't real out there it's this it's
this satire conspiracy theory like it's
if gabe one of gabe's video like comes
to life and creates this this movement
this birds aren't real
is um and what's this kid's name i i
forget um peter
mc ma
his name is peter he's the founder of
birds aren't real right yeah so he runs
around the country saying that birds are
aren't real they're it's a government
conspiracy the origin story is pretty
interesting like how it just kind of
came into being
like basically they were watching uh and
i think they covered in one of the
videos but basically in 2017 after the
inauguration people were like marching
in protest and be like oh you know trump
we don't want him in office and he he
was on the roof with some friends and he
was like oh man it'd be kind of crazy if
somebody went out there and just started
yelling random things in protest for
something totally unrelated
and um yeah like jfk jesus or something
right exactly that would be really weird
yeah
so he went down there and he wrote he
wrote this sign is that birds aren't
real and he's like they're a conspiracy
there uh there's a birdemic it's all
that it's fake it and it took off
and it yeah it took off and then he had
people sending him photos of like
graffiti and and uh different things
that were written um
in uh
on walls and and photos and pictures and
like all these things that he had been
sent and he was like oh man this is
really taken off and then he i mean he
does ridiculous things but again like i
think one of the co-founders there's
three of the students that were also
friends with him and they also happened
to be survivors of
a school shooting
and they were saying like
the conspiracy of like people say i'm a
christ sector and my dad is a sex
trafficker because he's like an adoption
agent or attorney and uh all these
random things and the girl was like
we're just fighting lunacy with lunacy
right
that's the world we live in right now
and it truly it truly is uh clowning the
clowns right oh yeah and the people who
cause you know to some degree and we're
gonna watch some video from this trump
rally that's absolutely [ __ ] batshit
crazy to some degree we talk about this
a lot where
we believe that
you know we're at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life and these
people may not really believe this stuff
they're just pretending because it's fun
but listen listen to how how of course
he breaks character eventually in this
little interview
but listen to
how committed he is um to some of these
questions about birds aren't real this
is hilarious what bird is most
suspicious to you really every bird how
do you feel about seagulls uh i don't
trust him
i'll tell you that have you ever been to
the beach and you got some food left
over and seagull comes over and tries to
get it that's not because it's hungry
you know the mainstream media wants to
sell us this lie that oh birds are
hungry uh you know when in fact the
seagulls are taking your food to bring
it back to the pentagon for dna
uh harvesting and testing so this sounds
absolutely batshit crazy and it only
makes me believe that q anon would
believe this stuff hook line sinker if
it wasn't
they've also put out different like as
this built up they started releasing
videos of like
uh the undiscloser unreleased or uh you
know um
uh the the the classified video of this
xcia um operative who worked on these uh
on this like birds aren't real like
program right and how they were just uh
robots
wrapped up in a bird's eye drones or
whatever right exactly
and so in this one they're in the
interview they're talking about this as
well and he and she's like oh so like
what happened and he was like i was just
looking for like the oldest guy i could
find like as an actor right and then
they interviewed him and they made it
they made it seem like he was
interviewing this old guy who had been
his ex-cia and he was in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] of
these birds this bird operation
and uh it was like bird drone deployment
or something like that i think is the
name and then they released it and it
went viral they did they've done all
these things since then as it's like
built up and people being like oh yeah
birds are real and they were like having
a conversation and those people believe
this stuff oh no for sure because they
had they had a bit in this interview
where they were talking about like oh do
you interact with people who
legitimately believe birds aren't real
and they're like yeah we also talk to
people
and they're like oh yeah i totally knew
that i totally knew that like they're
they're all [ __ ] it's it's cia and
they're like
okay all right these are the same people
because we watched the video last week
of walter masterson had a couple rallies
where he's like um
and then they're like anti-mass
anti-vaxxy and they're like where should
i get the these numbers and they're like
the cdc website and he's like well can
you trust the cdc they're like no no but
you can trust your website yeah but you
can't trust them it's just it's [ __ ]
you can't make this [ __ ] up like yeah
well it's the same people who are like i
won't get the vaccine but uh or they're
like trump should get credit for like
just speeding through cutting the red
tape and the bureaucracy of getting the
vaccine available to everyone well you
take it oh no no that was rushed it's
like right within a within 30 seconds of
answering the question right they're
like
no i'm not gonna get the backstage yeah
yeah i'm not gonna do that not gonna do
it and they're like it's because of my
bodily autonomy and right you can't you
cannot take away any liberty to
someone's body of the autonomy period
end of story what about abortion oh we
gotta abolish abortion we gotta take
that away we can't have women making
health decisions that's ridiculous i was
their own bodies so yesterday i was
going through some boxes of like i had
like old old uh papers and documents
that my mom had sent me and i was going
to be like oh what do i actually need
and what do i don't need
and in there
i found my [ __ ] vaccine report card
and it was like from like school when
you were yeah yeah from school and it
was like wait wait wait wait gabe wait
gabe that's probably a fake document
it's probably i don't know it looks
pretty authentic to me you know
it had the dates written in there and
the type of vaccine i was getting any
anyone anyone could have faked that
anyone no i don't know man would my mom
lie to me i don't think well i mean is
she part of the mainstream media and
does she believe the mainstream media
does she watch the mainstream media game
well she is a nurse so she may be well
yep she could be part of the deep state
uh vaccine cabal let's let's finish
listening to
um this hilarious this hilarious satire
um and and she can hardly keep a
straight face while he's saying some of
this which this is it feels like when
you're watching this and when she's
watching it it feels like sometimes when
me or you are watching q and on
the q anon rallies where they're saying
some of this stuff and we're laughing at
them because it's so hilarious that they
won't even say [ __ ] like this you're
like you can't be serious right you
really believe that there's no way a
person believes this [ __ ]
how do you feel about 60 minutes i'm
surprised you've decided to sit here
with us i'm not gonna go on news shows
but
shows about
you know clocks and time i'm okay with
sharing um my information with and i i
understand this isn't anything like the
media so
thanks thanks for having me on your on
your clock show with that he finally
broke character and we met the real
peter mcendu you're the person that i've
been hearing about but haven't seen okay
great it was wonderful to meet you yeah
nice so go watch it go watch this venue
peter mcadoo apparently is how you say
is say his name and she got it right
there go watch this um go watch this
interview and really honestly show it to
your your q and on relatives maybe maybe
just maybe
i saw some kids yeah i saw some people
in the in the thread
in the comments yesterday they're like
i've been wondering for so long why my
students keep telling me birds aren't
real they're chanting in the cafeteria
they're saying it in class
uh
so this so this is like this is like
someone who's who's a teacher right yeah
a teacher she's like i don't understand
why these kids are saying this and then
she's like and now i totally understand
now i get it right so she so she was
like this is just some kind of weird
thing that they're doing
well you know this is the same [ __ ]
where like uh and we're gonna watch ted
cruz here capitulate um and and [ __ ]
about capitulators and ass kissers when
he's
he's a capitulator himself yeah
endorsing one of the biggest trump ass
kissers there is but it's crazy because
these parents i have a couple teacher
friends too and they say the same thing
like like these kids walk around and
they say the q anon type stuff right and
and he'll like he he's challenged a few
of them a
specific friend of mine i've talked to
him about it he's like you know i ask
him certain questions and
and they're like why because my my
parents say this like i heard it
somewhere right right like this is how
this stuff starts this is how this
nonsense starts and speaking of nonsense
let's listen to cancun cruise here just
absolutely i mean the irony can't even
just
you can't even hardly describe it let's
listen
when i look to candidates i don't look
to what they say on the stump because
they all say the same darn thing
every candidate says i love donald trump
no no i love donald trump more no no i
have got a trump tattooed on my rear end
like literally this guy this he has
donald trump right dude
this is even hard to even commentate on
this really it is because this is
[ __ ] ridiculous
that that he would say this type of [ __ ]
and the irony not just smack i think
people like like laughing and they're
like oh that's funny and that's true and
it's like come on give me a [ __ ] word
yesterday we were talking about
something totally unrelated and i said
the phrase cuck of a cuck
and i swear
this is a good example of a huck of a
cuck
the ted cruz
cucking
for
mandel
who is another cuck
of trump
who is the cup of the cup you know what
it is it's like the human uh cockapeed
is what it is oh the cockapeed yeah
that's a good one the human cockapede
the cockapeed it's just going to be a
graphic somewhere i'm going to make a
graphic i will make a graph okay good
good cocopeat well everyone look out for
the cockapeed graphic speaking of
[ __ ] trump cucks
this is a video of of some people on an
airplane who at the end they believe
they're being kicked off because they're
trump supporters but what they're doing
is they're they're they're flinging homo
homophobic slurs at people on the plane
specifically people who are wearing
masks and maybe just maybe you [ __ ]
idiots the people wearing masks because
they're sick and they don't want to get
you sick but let's let's listen to this
nonsense even like the words
it's hard for me to even watch this the
second time it's it's kind of long and
what i mean long is you got to watch
these [ __ ] for more than a couple
minutes right what i don't understand is
like all of these dumb
trumpers right idiots [ __ ] idiots
whatever we're asking
yeah yeah no they're terrible people you
know especially because it's like oh i'm
a you know i'm a flight attendant and
i'm doing my job it's just like dude
fasten your seat belt make sure the
trays are up like you know make sure the
seats up like do you want do you want
snacks or drinks like i'm trying to make
sure that we get this [ __ ] plane off
the ground and you not making a big deal
about it but i thought these were the
same people that were like oh yeah you
know what we're going to start our own
airline okay then go do it dude like you
want to start your own social network
obviously that failed you want to start
your own airport or your airline go do
that yeah you'll spend a lot of [ __ ]
money but at the end of the day like
you're not going to do it because you
know what
you would rather [ __ ] and moan and
complain
and be in front of an audience right
exactly you would rather have the people
that hate you and make a big deal about
it and then play victim because here's
the thing if you were in a scenario
where you were with other people who are
the same in an echo chamber you can't
bench in moana you can't play victim
right because everyone else is just like
you right that's what they get they get
off on this of like oh i'm going to act
like a karen or i'm going to act like a
kevin orr i'm oppressed i'm oppressed
i'm oppressed
right you don't have to wear a mask
anymore what are you bitching and
moaning about right why are you bitching
and moaning and other people wearing
mess maybe they're [ __ ] sick and they
don't want to get you sick have you ever
thought about that you dumb
[ __ ] maybe those people who
have to travel and are like you know
have an immune system
autoimmune disease or like they're sick
or whatever you know or or they've had a
scratchy throat and they're still pest
testing native or covalent but for your
benefit they're going to put on a mask
to make sure to protect you from getting
it what what don't people understand
about this [ __ ] you don't know why that
motherfucker's got a mask on my body
my choice well i mean control only gabe
yeah only if it applies to the
their narrative right so if you look
here on the screen you see the fat
chubby guy the the the
and he's kind of a
sunglasses are the mask
well you know or is his sleep mask i
have over his eyes i don't know he
he's a [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] she's an
[ __ ] too and she continues on and and
they say in the video that they're not
going to get off the plane but listen to
hear hear what this [ __ ]
fat tub lard calls these people with
these masks and if you look here there's
a lady sitting here and grabbing uh this
guy who's got a mask on grabbing his arm
and it's probably a good thing because
he might have mike tyson this son of a
[ __ ] if you know what i mean but let's
watch let's watch what this guy this the
slurs that this guy slings at
you know what it's a beautiful day i'm
happy to stay one more night i am suing
you yeah okay for what i'm telling you
and buddy i gotta have that money in the
airline oh my god
[Music]
oh i'm offended
so he's he he he slings this homophobic
slur
you know in some countries it's known as
a small cigarette but here it is it is a
homophobic slur he calls him the f word
if you if you catch my drift i'm not
going to replay it but but i i assuming
they're doing it because they have mask
on now near the end because they're
going to get kicked off the plane here
and if you watch the vladimir then it
comes like you're getting off you're
getting off no i'm not getting off she
doesn't want him to get off um
the plane get off the plane um and
eventually they have to get off the
plane and at the moment
what happens is is the the [ __ ] pilot
says everyone off the plane everyone's
going off the plane which i don't blame
the pilot for making the entire [ __ ]
plane hate these [ __ ] yeah like
at this point the pilot they won't get
off the plane so basically the pilot's
like okay well fine if you don't get off
everyone's going to be punished and
they're going to punish you now right so
you're going to be the [ __ ] that
holds up this entire operation i would
rather clear everyone out right and just
bring to people who actually want to
[ __ ] leave right and you you said
just now oh it's nice outside i don't
mind standing in the night that's
totally fine go get your [ __ ] hotel i
[ __ ] right you know i don't know
whatever grab your bags a sec so listen
to what they say when they're leaving
how they're oppressed listen to this
[ __ ] what did we do
can you tell me what we said you gotta
get off the plane because we're trump
supporters they said i gotta get no no
you're you're you're you're slinging
homophobic slurs you're being an [ __ ]
that's what's happening you're acting
like trump supporters is where you're
getting kicked off because you're acting
like trump right you're
you're saying vile stuff disgusting
homophobic slurs like you said and and
you're expecting for people to just look
at you and say like oh you know what
they're actually the victims here in the
situation right
look at these oppressed white people
these oppressed drunk white people look
at them look at them let's give them
attention well here they got the
attention they they they needed and
deserved and actually um let me give
credit here for this video um
50 shades has the
the follow-up video here is here is when
they enter
the terminal off the plane this is
fantastic you talk about you talk about
a
a celebration to the birthday party here
i'm going to give you the video all the
way through here because you're going to
like this one
you know i'm not sure what airport this
is in
but they do get kicked out
and
obviously the people on the plane are
like thank god you get them off the
[ __ ] plane uh this is how you get 86
from an airline if you're at an airport
right well people are like oh i uh
people they don't let me in like the
denver airport anymore it's like well
what do you do it's like i can't talk
about it and you don't want to talk
about it you can't go in the denver
airport anymore are you saying you don't
want to talk about it no no no no let's
talk about it
no no no no i'm not i'm not banff you're
just you're just giving me but i do i do
occasionally find myself on no fly list
just because my name is common for
i guess people who do bad things
what's funny is they think they got
kicked off to be because they are trump
supporters right but in the end they
proved like you said the reason why
these people hate these people who are
coming off this plane they're booing
them because you didn't get kicked off
because you're trump supporters but
you're getting booed
because you are trump supporters yeah
and really there's a few people standing
there if you see the one lady she's kind
of like she's upset that she has to get
off the plane she's not going to boo
these people
because she probably voted for trump she
probably likes all the trump [ __ ] but
honestly this kind of stuff is the [ __ ]
that's gonna keep people at at home in
the midterms like i may voted for him
but i'm tired of this [ __ ] i'm tired of
these [ __ ] crazy ass q and honors i'm
tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ] on airplanes
where people are i'm oppressed i'm white
and so you're you're oppressing me in
this kind of [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here um speaking of white people um
being oppressed
transition
donald trump oppressed uh jd vance this
weekend at his rally did you see this
clip gabe i i did okay well i put
together a video here about jd vance and
this weekend and i just want to play it
then we'll go play the uh the entirety
of the trump of the trump clip but let's
watch i agree with trump he's certainly
the best president yeah my wife knows he
was a fighter for people that i care
about more than any politician in the in
the in this country in in 30 40 years
i'm on the team as the president said jd
gets it so this is jamie vance it's jd
vance vance van j
d
vance it really is not that hard i mean
if you're going to adore someone at
least memorize their name right
isn't that what you do i mean i would
you know listen there's only one vance i
know and it's bob vance
from the office so i don't know who this
jd vans guy is so i don't know or who he
thinks he is well let's let's listen to
what trump said at israelites that's
what they're waiting for they're waiting
for one race you know we've endorsed dr
ross we've endorsed
jp right
jd mandel jd mandela
ah jd you are such a shitbox you
sycophanted for this [ __ ] so he would
he would get your name confused right
with your running mate's name who was
trying to kiss his ass dude and they say
joe biden is incompetent right and has a
is sleepy right dementia and and you
know a lot of people are are pointing
out that possibly donald trump has
dementia over this um i actually don't
think that is the case of what happened
here here's what i think happened i
think donald trump doesn't give two
shits about people in ohio doesn't give
a [ __ ] about people in ohio including jd
mandel or josh vance yeah i think that's
right the only thing he cares about is
the money that's coming in that's right
he gets paid to do this rally then he
gets money and therefore he's like yeah
sure i'll show up but he doesn't give
two [ __ ] doesn't remember who they are
like you could you could put him in a
lineup and he'd be like
all these white guys look the same i
don't know like that's honestly what it
is right like he couldn't tell you
who any of there were if no if this is a
you know if there's like a five six
person seven person lineup he'd be like
i don't know maybe four maybe
here's the clip from rsbn so people know
that i didn't like [ __ ] no this is
not edited [ __ ] around right this was
streamed live with rsbn here is the clip
it's only it's only 12 seconds long
where he [ __ ] up his name but listen
that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for one race you know we've
endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great they're all doing
good they're that's i'd like to get i
like to get jd mandel on the show uh
yeah we should have jd we could if we
could find them yeah maybe we'll get
tomorrow maybe maybe we'll track down jd
mandel who is running for senate who was
endorsed by trump maybe his thing maybe
jd mandel wasn't even running but now
he's like [ __ ] people are gonna write me
in right you know might as well well and
and even jp mandel might have some
viability here right because if you see
in the beginning trump is not sure if
it's jd or jp yeah you can't really
figure that out
and he turns he turns to ask someone
watch this
jp right
jp right is that who it is is that who
we endorse simon i think that's
something i don't know who the [ __ ]
knows
if someone off to the side is like uh
like what he doesn't [ __ ] know yeah
he's like that [ __ ] has him or he has
a big cue card and he's like jd
right
yeah maybe that's what happened maybe
they got it wrong yeah is is they put
mandel because they don't know who he is
maybe he should just stick to the
teleprompter you know he really rags on
the teleprompter and says i don't you
know what we start with the teleprompter
and then i go off and i'm i'm the guy
i'm the teleprompter guys worst
nightmare like that's trump saying
verbatim about the teleprompter and then
also you know throwing biden onto the
bus for saying like oh biden uses the
teleprompter so does pretty much every
other politician
but when you look at this it's like
maybe you should be looking at the
teleprompter but then again you did
blame the teleprompter when you said
there were airports in 1776 so or the
revolutionary war or whatever it was
right well i mean you know you know
typical trump you know history right now
my not my fault someone else did it i
i'm not taking the blame not my
responsibility well here here you said
jd mandel aka the candidate formerly
known as jd vance do you think jd
actually changes his name now like he
legally changes his name i think he has
to i think he's got a lean
my name is jj mandel
what i thought you were jd vance he goes
no no trump's oh my god mandel and now i
am jd mandel yay gabe we we have to get
out ahead of this because i'm almost
sure that jd vance is probably gonna
have to run an ad saying i'm jd vance
not jd mandel yeah i'm jd vance yeah i'm
not gonna happy here look
look on this look what i wrote here
will the real jd mandel please stand up
that's all i want to know that's all i
want to know where is he
where is he i i don't i you know
you can't make this [ __ ] up and really
again i think a lot of people are over
over exaggerating when they think this
is mental capacity that is preventing
trump from this is literally he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about who he endorses he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if republicans win
the senate he doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah
no he doesn't he really does not give up
two [ __ ] he gifter only cares about the
money that's right that's right he's
doing it right there in the moment he's
like how many people said they love me
oh so many
president trump so many he's like okay
good good good good well speaking of the
weird ass [ __ ] that gop says um might as
touch our partners at midas touch have a
video out uh yesterday called weird gop
and they are [ __ ] weird there's some
weird ass [ __ ] that they're doing and
we're gonna get to the q anon videos i
want to show you a couple of these
videos gabe because
at this trump rally
it just you can't
it's it's hard to even make it up in
your mind so that you can get out in
front of it like yeah you just can't
anymore but let's listen to this video
the weird stupid [ __ ] that they say and
they believe and that happens inside the
gqp problem is they are a weird
political point
m ms will not be satisfied until every
last cartoon character is deeply
unappealing until the moment you
wouldn't want to have a drink with any
one of them there's 26 q anon people q
is a patriot q a non-believers lined up
on the grassy knoll it's the site of the
jfk assassination they believe that the
president's late son jfk jr would
miraculously appear and that he would
help donald trump take back power i want
to talk about the real pandemic child
sex trafficking by putting mass on these
kids face you guys support sex
trafficking been a good little nazi it's
not necessarily the extreme
people that talk about testicle tanning
testicles
technical tanning half the viewers right
now are like what that's called i'm
tanning my testicles right now my view
is okay testosterone levels crash and
nobody says anything about it that's
crazy by and large a large part of the
republican party is just out and out
weird then all of a sudden you get
invited to like hey we're going to have
kind of a
sexual get-together at one of our homes
you should come and then you realize
they're asking you to come to an orgy
you got a lot of really crazy people the
front runners of the ohio republic
there's jd mandela a heated fight when
do we invade australia and free and
oppress people in florida the state
education department rejected more than
50 mouth textbooks maybe they're
promoting critical race theory the
democrats are the party of princess
predators from disney disney's stepping
in saying you know in every episode now
they're going to have mickey and pluto
going at it what like i don't know
really that never happened
the antidote that we've seen now is
urine
satan's controlling the church calling
gingerbread men a gingerbread person
when obviously they're men mr mrs potato
head dr seuss dr seuss dr seuss when
they say the noise causes cancer prayer
absolutely normal yep they're really
like odd ducks
man
oh bret bread at midas touch really does
know how to put them together doesn't it
yeah oh my god it's
it re you can't even hardly make this
[ __ ] up but but they literally are and
we're going to go to some of these uh
events in this in this footage here now
the one video i want to go to is
speaking about
uh
jfk and jfk junior the good liars and
i'm not sure exactly what rally this is
from gabe i don't know if this is from
this any rally really it just really
doesn't matter what q and on nazi
railway this is from yeah but you see
this uh this guy here he's got a trump
hat on he's got the tie on i guess
that's a trump tie i don't i don't know
i think it's a little too short it's got
to be a lot longer and a lot better it's
got to go way down past his tan balls
for sure
um he's got the trump cape on it looks
like a flag that he's tied up to be a
cape he's got the i don't know if this
is a trump bag he's got bracelets i mean
this guy's really committed he's got his
little tote bag he's ready to collect
all the swag right right but if you
notice his he's got a q on his shirt
here if you see this here he's got a
cube and then he's got a a negative 48.
i wasn't aware of what that is but let's
listen to what this guy says because i
actually had to look up a few things for
this video to prep for this show and
believe it or not i i now have to prep
for cueing on conspiracy theories of
videos of people showing up at q anon
rallies these trump nazi rallies and
really honestly we've been saying this
is it it gets crazier i think
because the dumber these people get it's
not really that they're getting dumber
it's just the dumbest ones showing up at
these rallies yeah like it's just it's
everyone's peeling off but the stupidest
[ __ ] but let's listen to what
this guy what he believes listen tell us
about it what is what is negative 48.
okay well negative 48 is michael brian
protzman okay so he says negative 48 and
you see it here q
right the little q on the 48 and it
looks like he's homemade this shirt
right this isn't like something he's
bought maybe like the n equals
i guess like negative right
now he says uh
brian um
what does he say michael brian prodsman
right michael brian prodsman if you
remember several months back there was
hundreds of trump supporters
q and honors who went down to dallas to
watch jfk junior appear you remember
this i don't know and you know what
right well and if you if you guys are
unaware of this story
this cult leader because really this is
like a subsect of q anon is what i did a
little bit of research on this guy this
prodsman he was get he was holding up
people in hotel rooms in a hyatt hotel
in dallas and i'm not sure if they're
still there but he was making them drink
each other's pee and all kinds of weird
ass [ __ ] he was taking their phones away
from them he was kind of you know
imprisoning them almost in this hotel
room waiting for jfk junior to appear
that's who this guy is believing
um this negative 48 this
this prodsman but let's listen to what
this guy believes he is teaching
jamaitria michael jackson saying about
it abc oh my god
so this is so this is the thing that we
seen last week uh i think a week ago is
that there was a really yeah there was a
video it was rsbn as well or as rsbn and
and the woman was talking about how
princess diana was alive right right
exactly and they also same thing who
taught them geometry was geometry
matriarchy
i think is what they call it like where
did how did we go
fro to that from geometry like it's not
a hard word to say geometry
this is what happens when you get rid of
books this is what happens
right when you ban math books but here's
the thing this to believe this right to
believe this game you have to believe
that 50 [ __ ] years ago
that michael jackson as a child
sang
abc 123 to now today somehow
make this all make sense to make sure
that trump
saves the planet or some weird-ass [ __ ]
but it gets even it gets even weirder
here it gets even weirder listen to this
and so what is demetria
one two exactly
a being one and z being twenty right so
michael jackson
was he part of negative 48 no but he is
uh you keep saying is is he is he he's
alive brother
michael jackson's not dead michael
jackson is alive so michael jackson is
now alive
he's not dead that was all staged
how many years when did michael jackson
die when the [ __ ] did he die 2 000 what
seven
it's been it's been a long time no no no
it's it's been like 08 09
it's been longer than 10 years he's been
dead
see michael jackson surely surely he's a
9 2009.
2017. so we're talking 13 years that
motherfucker's been dead yeah dead dead
dead look if he were to if he were to
talk about tupac and say tupac is still
alive i might i might bend my ear for
him you know i might listen okay when he
says
michael jackson you're almost
i'm like that's not geometry like are we
are we talking about like a squared b
squared c squared but even then that's
that's no it's a song game a b c
but how does it get z at 26. what does z
because because a is one b is two c is
three d is four right okay but z is
never mentioned
no not in the song yeah yeah but in the
alphabet right but in his mind he's like
he's actually telling me to go to right
right they're giving you clues they're
giving it's only hints gabe it's only
him they would never say out loud they
would never see the question little tiny
bread crumbs they're like right specs of
a breadcrumb and
years of breadcrumbs
michael jackson the kid not michael
jackson the adult yeah michael jackson
the child who was singing
with his brothers and sisters this is
the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever heard
oh it oh it gets [ __ ] dumber it gets
[ __ ] dumber you're going to be you're
going to be pleasantly surprised i'm
going to leave the show let's listen in
absolutely
okay let's bring let's bring him back
back here for a second
who do you think
really he was resurrected four days
later as jesus christ
jfk was a resurrected gabe as jesus
[ __ ] christ i'm not [ __ ] you you
cannot make this [ __ ] up this guy is
standing here believing that not jfk
junior we're not talking about the kid
that jfk's kid that died in a plane
crash in the 1990s we're talking about
jfk who got his [ __ ] head shut off in
in daley plaza down in dallas when he
was president united states he's saying
that he was resurrected as jesus christ
and it gets [ __ ] even weirder than
this but that is the weirdest [ __ ] i
have ever see
what year was jfk born can you look that
up real quick what the [ __ ] year was he
born how old would that [ __ ] be
if he was if he didn't die if it was
some kind of statement
he's born in 1917 he would be 105 years
old right 105 is how old jfk would be
today if he was alive or resurrected
whatever the [ __ ] yeah whatever whatever
i don't know oh my god it gets worse it
gets worse stay in your seat because i'm
telling you this gets crazier listen to
this
just like
jfk was resurrected as jesus christ
absolutely
absolutely why why
he is your president why would jfk come
back as jesus christ why would jesus
christ come back as jesus christ
jesus christ do we have to go over this
[Laughter]
i mean really honestly
if if you look here it looks like he's
got his hand on his back like look i
know the truth and you don't know the
dream buddy
i'm gonna help you through i'm gonna
walk you through this right this is a
male dominant mansplaining thing where a
guy puts his like look
let me tell you how it really is and i
understand how dumb you are right that
you don't know these things because i
found this on on telegram because that's
apparently where all this come from this
prodsman he became some kind of
influence a q anon influencer on
telegram he gained
a following of several hundred thousand
on telegram and he started to to
perpetuate this stuff on telegram and
that's where these people believe this
stuff but listen to what he says about
jfk being president absolutely and he is
your president
and junior is your vice president as we
speak
he believes this guy is standing there
saying he believes that jfk is
resurrected as jesus christ and he's
currently our president and his son who
died in a plane crash in the 1990s
is our vice president now
to believe this you would have to
believe that all the policies that this
guy probably blames on joe biden like if
you ask him well what about what about
the gas prices whose fault is that what
about all the empty store shelves what
about all the inflation what about all
whose fault is that they would say he
would say joe bidens for sure
but it's jfk and and jfk junior are
actually the president but it's all
biden's fault i don't
understand go sideways that's the real
biden right when things go well are you
sure that's not james wood or jim carrey
in a mask i mean it could be that i
don't know i mean that's what the other
person told the good liars as well you
thought last week when we heard that a
lady thought joe biden was jim carrey to
ask you like that's the craziest [ __ ]
i'll ever hear nope here we are this
week here we are this week talking about
how jfk and jfk jr are jesus christ
resurrected and they're our president
and vice president and someone um might
as marge margie says why the kennedys
were democrats that i mean if you're
really looking for logic in this in the
the road map to
get right let's let's finish listening
to
president wackadoo here as we speak
right now jfk senior as president and
jfk junior's vice president absolutely
that doesn't even doesn't even flinch
yeah doesn't even flinch gabe doesn't
even flinch he's like abso [ __ ]
lutely you god damn right yep you god
damn right he is and it just it's
[ __ ] alarming um here's another video
that patriot takes um put out of of alex
jones and really honestly and i don't
know if you guys can can give us some
input out there i'm really thinking
about doing our cold open here on the
show just like this like yeah i really
want to start doing the cold open like i
have to really train your voice right i
know get into that level
you know the alex jones we're gonna have
to add like subtitles i know i know
the ominous you know yeah background and
stuff but i really am considering doing
the cold opens like like like this and
hang on till the end this is long and it
is gruesome and cringy and it's tough to
watch but the very end it's worth it the
the the launch that he has and the exit
here the landing here is oh it's my it's
beautiful watch alex jones in his cold
opening of his show
you you will pay for what you've done
and i pray that god send angels to visit
vengeance upon you
but none of us will harm a hair on your
filthy murderous heads but god will
crush you
crush you
you will be destroyed not us
our will breaks you
god breaks
bill gates bill gates god breaks bill
gates
oh boy this is i mean this is kind of
rough right this is kind of rough yeah i
don't know man i feel like i feel like i
need a minute to walk this off like this
dude could co could we manage to do a
cold open like this i mean i'm yeah sure
we can totally do this your family would
probably hate you but right but hey i'm
good i'm good with doing a cold open i
think we should do every cold open where
i just go on some kind of crazy ass
kind of you know often left field what
is he talking about here i don't know
like i mean is there some story in the
bible he's talking about i don't know
but here's the thing is these people
know they know the code words they know
the language and he's speaking to his
he's he's sending me a message man uh mj
says no
no no don't
don't
don't don't don't do that don't
clearly i'm joking but listen to the
dismount here it's
it's kind of beautiful if you really
think about it
you might you might change your mind him
jay let's listen to this
you understand that yeah i think i'm
bear no no do not i do not understand a
single word he's talking about you will
be visited by the spirit of god is he is
he doing an exorcism is that what he's
doing god descends the angel of death
what the [ __ ]
and he sends the angel of death with
wrath yeah this is that he's actually
impress us
you will never stop us
you will never take our birth right
people tune into this stuff
now that i've said
oh my god yep
let us watch this to the news
this is the best part this is the best
part
now that i've said that to satan and his
minions
let us move
to the news
i mean
can't you just listen to this video
i'll tell you
the devil knows
not to come to us
so
listeners
welcome to the tony michaels podcast i
mean i was thinking like
now that i have made sure that satan
knows that tony michaels has damned you
to hell
let's round up the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends i mean that's what i'm
thinking
he's like and on that note uh how about
we see what's going on in the world yeah
yeah let's check out what the newspapers
are saying today folks i don't know what
the [ __ ] what is that what the hell is
that i don't i don't even know what you
just made us all watch tony no i'm sorry
i i found it hilarious i found it
hilarious that that these like a lot of
people are like oh dude the batman voice
and you're like i'm batman but then this
one is like do
do the alex jones voice
i mean literally it is the intersection
between wrestlemania and real life i
mean honestly this is you cannot make
this [ __ ] up speaking of making [ __ ] up
speaking of making [ __ ] up i'm not
making this up mike lindell
mike lindell
the pillow guy you know the my to here
are you are you familiar with this guy
gabe have you heard of him i heard i
heard
he may or may not have facetimed me this
weekend but i don't know
are we going to have maybe uh a video
screen cap of this or something possibly
okay okay well let's let's watch mike
lindell because listen to what he says
he he appears to be
on his private plane i'm surprised he
still has this thing really yeah yeah
he's burning where the money's coming
well coming from rudy giuliani you know
really
oh yeah rudy
he's like hey thanks for watching the
rudy giuliani show and this has been
sponsored by my pillow slippers slippers
and schlippers
oh my god but mike lindell the my pillow
gay
he's lost his mind lost his twitter
account but apparently he may have had
it back
for just a little bit let's listen in
here
everyone to twitter this mike lindell
i'm here to tell you about my new
account here at mike j lindell at mike j
lindell that's the only account over
here at twitter that i'm using all those
other ones are fake accounts and they've
been using my name out there so we
started this account please share with
everybody you know let everybody you
know so we can get the word out over
here on twitter in case they do take it
down and thanks a lot for helping out
thank you now within hours i'm talking
like two hours he was already crying in
his pillow his my pillow because this
was taken down almost immediately i
think and it's very it's very unclear to
me it looks like he just opened a new
account with his middle initial in it
and just tried to open up a new account
yeah and he thought oh elon musk will
allow me will allow me elon owns twitter
he owns twitter already tony
that's what the iguy told us yeah i know
i know
that but is this seriously what he
thought that he thought he could just
open an account because elon's
pretending to buy twitter he thought he
could just open an account what the hell
is yeah i think 100 a lot of a lot of
these people are like oh i can say
whatever i want now i can do whatever i
want i was banned before i can come back
on the platform all because
elon musk supposedly owns twitter now
which again he does not own twitter he
has yet to secure all of the financing
he has not signed any documents to say
elon musk owns twitter and what's funny
about it is he's tanking all his value
by not you know doing this in the
appropriate way and it seems like this
morning this uh shadow crew thing is
trending around that that they actually
goaded him into pretending to buy this
thing but before we skipped anything
like that let's look at how mike
lindell's new account is doing over on
twitter
this is a screen gap that i did of a
yesterday it is suspended the craziest
part is is there's a few uh what appear
to be mike lindell accounts that are
still up but i think they're using and i
i texted you about this yesterday i
think they're using in the in the uh end
of lindell they're using a capital i
instead of an l yeah um is what they're
doing and i don't know if that counts
been suspended or not but here's what i
said i said someone page elon musk
freedom of speech
it clearly it clearly is that mike
lindell thought oh well elon owns i
heard i heard on the tweety tweets that
elon owns twitter so i can open me an
account or some [ __ ] is that what is
that what you're catching here i don't
know i would assume again i i very much
assume that these people who thought
they were banned or that they got in
trouble before for saying stuff were
like oh elon owes twitter he owns it he
owns it he he he could he could bring me
back on he can make things right again
he he can make my life whole that's
exactly what the people think
it's really kind of [ __ ] crazy why
doesn't he go over the true social i
don't know why doesn't he i want to know
let's see is he on to social i look it
up right now i don't know but why why
you're doing that i opened a true social
account game yeah that's right i opened
a true social account just to see how
long it would take me to get banned over
there really um i said so true social
censored my jd mandel video um
where are all my freedom of speeches at
um because yesterday i i opened this
account and i posted that video that i
showed you that i made of jd vance look
what happened look what happened here
sensitive they censored the jd vance
video i didn't have anything vulgar in
it i didn't type out cuss words jd
didn't cuss trump didn't cuss in it it
was just simply i was pointing out that
trump's a dumb ass and they censored it
immediately like it never showed the
video look look at the time stamp on
this
zero minutes this was up so i posted
this went to my page to see if it was up
immediately they had censored it
immediately
that is crazy so if you're on true
social which you shouldn't be but if
you're on through social
go follow us at tony michael's pod over
there we're going to see how long it
takes us
to get banned and gabe i have some stuff
to talk to you about after the show
about this i actually had several people
retweet some of my uh
some of my content my great content that
i've got over there
on true social
and here's the thing they retweeted it
they re-truth it
whatever the [ __ ] it is it's something
it's some play on truth you're like hey
when you when you instead of like
tweeting it's just truth like that's not
it truth is not a verb you can't truth
right well that's not how that works i
guess you truth it over there i don't
know i don't know whatever you do over
there um that [ __ ] crazy ass app it's
really kind of clunky and it's hard to
figure out it's not real i mean it's
sort of like twitter but it's not really
like twitter yeah yeah it's it really
it's like a wish.com version of twitter
if you were going to order one you know
what i mean right you know it's just not
the same but here's the thing
is that a couple
what seems to be actual accounts that
have thousands of followers liked some
of my post
and they were definitely not pro-trump
but these accounts were pro-trump which
makes me think gabe
makes me think what you said was true
where they're creating all these
accounts and these accounts are going
and liking all this stuff
and creating this quote-unquote
engagement yeah um so i mean if these
are pro-trump accounts and your video is
clearly not pro-trump and they're
they're liking it just blindly either
one there's a bunch of idiots on the
platform which yeah that's totally true
or two there's a bunch of bots who go in
and uh will like content to drive up
engagement just they're just cr they're
seating they're just creating fodder
it's nothing real there's not actual
like substance behind it it's just a
bunch of ghost accounts it's kind of
like it's like a shadow crew you know
right it's just like they got certain
accounts on there and then they got the
bots to create the engagement for those
accounts exactly and that that's it
that's it so it's it's a literally an
echo chamber full of bots that make you
feel like you're engaging but you're not
really
what it seems like when people talk
about oh you know what this is going to
be the uh the uprising of robots and ai
and stuff
like honest to god i think that this app
is going to create some sort of like uh
uh
just
a new bean of sorts you know like i
don't know you know if it's really gonna
cause a bunch of damage but i do think
that this thing will learn on its own
and become
ultra trump on this ultra trump ultra
trump
like like mega man or some [ __ ] like
that like i don't know what it is but i
think it's going to learn on its own and
become
its own it's going to be sentient it's
just gonna become its own bean right so
it's like the the the terminator but
more like yeah maybe the the [ __ ] inator
or something like that yeah yeah so
speaking of bots because this shadow
crew is is uh trending i said i've had
elon's shadow crew all up in my mentions
the last three weeks elon musk farms the
manliest incel cuckbots on the planet
like
literally that's what it felt like over
on true social that um and maybe elon
does elon have a true social account i
don't know he was bragging about teresa
i couldn't find mike lindell but also
remember mike lindell's still trying i
guess also
trying to get his uh his own so he's
still trying to get his own thing
started which
when he made his website it's just a
website there's no social network aspect
to it there's no social media platform
uh mike lindell is burning cash where i
don't know where the [ __ ] he's getting
this money from but he's burning cash
um
or or burning pillows either one i don't
know but at the end of the day like he's
trying to make his own social media
platform that's competing with getter
which is competing with you know jason
miller former trump amigo
uh then he's competing with gab which is
competing with true social like none of
these apps
have figured it out
because it's a bunch of people who are
saying the same thing and it's again
it's just one echo chamber after another
echo chamber and they're gonna censor
you it's not about freedom of speech
it's about them saying the vile stupid
[ __ ] that they want to say without
consequence that's what it's about and
and speaking speaking of saying vile
stupid things without consequences did
you did you check out the white house
correspondent some of the clips from
it is there are some great clips but
there's one clip that i want to show
with trevor noah so let's take a quick
break we'll be back right after this i
want to show this clip of trevor noah
and and there is a one joke in it but
the way that he frames this up is
[ __ ] beautiful and all the media
should listen to this so don't stay
tuned stay right here we'll be right
back after this message
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thank you for joining us at the tony
michaels podcast every single week and
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch and now
streaming from
midas touch facebook page if you're over
on the books of face in the minute meta
universe
go ahead and click that little link
there on on the broadcast that will take
you to our youtube channel and subscribe
to our youtube channel you do not want
to miss a thing over here subscribe
you like that you like that graphic
that's a good one i like that graphic
and and while you're there while you're
there on facebook you might as well like
the post as well it's speaking of
graphics there you go
like it
like it
you know the nice part about uh coming
and watching this podcast live on
youtube gabe
is that you can participate in the super
chat yeah you can give the super chat
which is kind of cool which is kind of
cool so if you guys and you guys can
chat in there
on facebook on youtube
on twitch but on twitter if you're
listening on twitter
to pull your comments through twitter
does this weird thing and maybe we
should um maybe we should ask elon about
this
um since he owns twitter now uh
we are pretending no on twitter we
should really figure out because the
twitter comments if you're commenting on
twitter they don't pull over here so we
can pull them up on the broadcast but
they do on youtube
facebook and twitch so that is another
reason to go
subscribe to the youtube channel so you
can watch this live on youtube and again
you don't want to miss any of these
clips and nice videos that we've been
working on that we post did you notice
gabe that we had seven days of the tony
michael's podcast last week i know it's
crazy
seven days a week that's right folks if
you're just now listening and just aware
we broadcast live monday through friday
for two hours every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central ninth pacific
but on saturdays now
coming to you
live
we have the best of the week so we take
the clips from the best of the week we
we put them together so you guys can
watch one show we also put that on the
directories gabe
yeah
also with bonehead of the week we clip
out bone of the week air that on sundays
so you can go watch it on the youtube
channel you can watch it on facebook you
can watch it on twitch or twitter or you
can download it on google apple spotify
wherever you get your podcast you can
download the tony michaels podcast now
seven
days a week but make sure to tune in
live every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central on
youtube twitter and twitch and now from
the minus touch facebook page
since we're talking about the media game
and we're talking about you know talking
to the main stream media yeah we're the
lame stream media right
there was a white house correspondents
dinner this weekend that is dedicated to
the media in this country following
politics in particular federal
politics and the federal government and
the politics of that of our country and
trevor noah was the the emcee i guess
you'd say the comedian that generally
goes yeah the funny part about this year
is the president actually is not a [ __ ]
he's not he showed up right he showed up
because he can take a [ __ ] joke like
literally joe biden he thinks jokes are
funny yeah and he can take a joke
because he's not a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
donald trump these people out there that
say oh you liberals are snowflakes and
i'm like get that [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] that's not even close
at least a liberal can take a joke and
donald trump and his supporters can't
even take a joke i'm sorry but also show
me one good conservative republican
comedian
right well for the same reason that i'm
always like show me one good
conservative republican
website or app that has been created
there exists none there are none it is
it is a myth it is it is
voodoo it's voodoo but gabe but gabe it
sucks to suck so you can't you know
you can't blame these folks it just it
sucks
so let's let's watch now there are
several clips from this and joe biden
has a couple slam dunks on on donald
trump but this clip here the end of of
trevor noah's uh bit here his speech
that he gave
um this is probably the most important
moment
from this entire event
that the media needs to listen to that
america needs to listen to because i
think it's very important how he frames
it here this is [ __ ] beautiful this
is brilliant i don't know
if trevor wrote this part if he had
writers i'm sure he did but yeah this
part here is absolutely brilliant how he
frames this so listen to what trevor
says about the media and how they act
and how they should report and how they
do their jobs every single one of you
whether you like it or not is a bastion
of democracy
and if you ever begin to doubt your
responsibilities
if you ever begin to doubt how
meaningful it is look no further than
what's happening in ukraine look at
what's happening there
journalists are risking and even losing
their lives to show the world what's
really
happening
you realize
how amazing it is like in america you
have the right
to seek the truth and speak the truth
even if it makes people in power
uncomfortable even if it makes your
viewers or your readers uncomfortable
you understand how amazing that is
i stood here tonight and i made fun of
the president of the united states and
i'm gonna be fine
i'm gonna be fine right
of course he had to throw a joke in
there you know right right like like do
you really understand what a blessing it
is maybe it's happened for so long that
you it might slip your mind it's a
blessing in fact here ask yourself this
question
honestly ask yourself this question
if if russian journalists
who are losing their livelihoods as you
were talking about
and their freedom for daring to report
on what their own government is doing
if they had the freedom
to write any words to show any stories
or to ask any questions if they had
basically what you have
would they be using it
in the same way that you do oh that's
cold ask yourself that question every
day
because you have one of the most
important roles in the world
thank you so much for having me
and that and that is probably
the wake-up call and and i don't know if
they will but that is the wake-up call
that the media needs and of course the
the the propagandists out there you know
they're they're [ __ ] freaking out
over this disinformation board and
calling it the ministry of truth and all
this [ __ ] and of course the the people
who are spreading the russian propaganda
and the disinformation are the ones
freaking out that the government's gonna
actually start to push back on the
disinformation that they're pushing
they're pissed off thank you mj for the
thank you super chat there but yeah i
mean trevor noah did a great job i
thought the jokes i mean here's the
thing uh
again we had four four years prior to
this where the president you know didn't
really show up right did he shoot the
first year or did he not show up any of
the years no um
biden said six years but this is the
sixth year i believe because right obama
showed up his last year right but trump
didn't show up for any of them and i
believe of course joe biden didn't show
up to the first year because yeah
because of the pandemic well well there
you go 2020 and 2021. there you go that
would be why it was six yeah this is so
this is the first time in six years that
a president showed up because the
president had the nuts to show up right
um because he could also i mean i want
to say that even even the joke about the
four years
you know
we haven't had a present here in six
years that joke i thought was very well
very well done and delivered uh you're
talking about from biden and and again i
could play a bunch of the tape from
biting slam dunking trump but really
honestly you know
i'm i'm not going to act like that i'm
some kind of [ __ ] sycophant for joe
biden yeah i will jokes
he told great jokes he's he read the
script he was supposed to read it just
as all the other presidents have ever
done
and participated in self-deprecating
humor and understood that it is
important it is important to laugh at
ourselves even when it's to laugh at the
truth that we are not perfect like
that's the whole [ __ ] point like and
that is the that is the difficult part
right now creating satire and comedy is
because these people get so [ __ ]
offended but the other thing they do too
is they make it up before we can like
yeah you can't even get out in front of
them for the satire and the parody of
themselves and that and that pisses them
off too and really pisses us off because
i think i think a big difference between
biden and trump in terms of just like
their approach to these um you know just
to humor is that like you know uh biden
is self-deprecating humor and trump is
self-defecating humor so right yeah well
that is true that was a shitty joke
whatever
yeah well uh good good one good one um
there is some breaking news here um that
i want to show you guys
as we're on the air
kyle griffin has it here he's the one of
the producers of the rachel maddow show
he says breaking the january 6 committee
is requesting cooperation from three
more house republicans who were either
involved with or had knowledge of the
events on and leading up to
those earned quotes uh the capital
insurrection they're looking and
requesting information from andy biggs
mo brooks and ronnie jackson of course
we know mo brooks is the one who wore
the the flak jacket that day the
bulletproof vest and he's also the one
who has been spotted on the local news
down in his race in alabama where trump
pulled his endorsement right has been
saying that the trump is delusional and
that he's fine so we might we might find
him provide information because this
whole like you know right and i don't
know
right i don't know if there's
communication maybe but ronnie jackson
ronnie jackson was just in the news last
week over the capital instruction
because remember ronnie jackson claimed
that day that he needed protection
because he had vital data
yeah and maybe that's what the january 6
select committee is looking for is that
data that he was trying to protect what
was he carrying that was in those texts
that he said oh you got to protect
ronnie jackson he has vital data right
so what do you make of this breaking
news that these three um because the
other the other one is it willingly or
they've been subpoenaed what did it say
um you know let me go back to the
let's look at the reports here let me go
to the trend
um because it is trending right now
ronnie jackson is trending and i believe
it's probably because
of that uh data
also boston city hall is trending that's
some breaking news too but let's go back
to this first um abc news is reporting
here breaking house january 6 select
committee has requested the cooperation
so it's not a subpoena it's just a
friendly hey you might want to cooperate
here
and i i i'm i'm probably the reason why
they're doing this is because it's house
members
you know asking other house members
their colleague colleagues to cooperate
so that may be but the one to look out
for here i think is mo brooks don't you
think after basically trump has thrown
him under the bus i mean yeah i think on
the living room yeah i think there's
potentially something interesting
there's yeah mo brooks and then also
whatever the data that ronnie jackson
had you know whether it was uh trump's
bmi score or what have you but i think
in the day like he had something
important and you wouldn't mention in
text that he had to be protected right
if there wasn't something there well i i
don't put it past ronnie jackson to lie
though to try because he was terrified
right that he may not make it out of the
camera right i mean these guys are these
guys are wimps they act like they're all
tough and [ __ ] but they're not they're
not tough at all and uh including andy
biggs andy biggs is a goes-r guy right
and that am i right he's he's a he's a
representative from arizona he's one of
the ones that pushed the uh
the the bamboo ballots and and the the
recount in arizona all that nonsense
with carrie lake
and the uh cyber ninjas right yeah
yeah so i've also got i've also got
another breaking news story right here
this approach 120 minutes ago it's
special grand jury members have been
selected for a trump election probe on
monday fulton county prosecutors
selected 23 people for a special grand
jury that will ultimately consider
whether
former president trump should be charged
for his attempts to pressure georgia
officials to overturn the results of the
2020 election
uh they decide whether the seeking
indictment from a regular grand jury
more to come so so is that is that in
the fulton county um
thread is there a fulton county threat
is there something else trending uh
it was it's the main
if you go to trending or at least for me
it was it was the main uh here's the
fulton county uh kyle has uh something
here
that's five hours ago but there's
something new huh yeah go go
here's cnn well we can't trust cnn you
know right
well if you go to here i'll send you the
article for the hill yeah send me send
me the article from the hill um
there's also some more breaking news it
looks like for boston city hall as we're
speaking while gage looking this up um
it looks like uh the supreme court has
unanimously ruled that boston violated
the first amendment when refusing to let
a group raise a christian flag at city
hall now some might see this as a win
for christians but um ultimately
the supreme court handing down this
ruling is a win for any religion that
would like to place their flag even a
satanic flag if you worship satan you
will be able to place your flag um as
they say
raise your flag i should say at the city
hall boston so all of you satanic
worshippers out there don't
don't remember or remember to make sure
to get your banner up and raising it
at the boston city hall because now it
is your constitutional right because the
supreme court says
it is your constitutional right to raise
the satanic flag or any religion really
gabe any religion can now put their i
mean that's what it means that's what it
means when the supreme court does these
things do these [ __ ] idiots really
realize what what they're doing when
they do this stuff
they're you know they they want freedom
of speech and they open the gates the
the the gates of hell is what they've
done and right now
you know
god is gonna come down and seek his
wrath on the devil like that's what okay
like
god he's going to come down and seek his
wrath on the satanic flag flyers of the
boston city hall i don't know i'm just
trying to do the art journal i mean if
you get if yeah if you if you get if you
get upset and you get the and honestly
get the way that you want where you like
i you know i want to
i want to celebrate whatever i want i
want to fly whatever flag i want well
guess what sorry it's called equality
and uh you you you you can't have your
cake you needed to where it's like i
wanna i wanna uh
fly a flag that's uh jesus christ
bearing the american flag while he like
comes out of the tomb or some [ __ ] like
that right like whatever it is that you
want it to be uh if you're gonna allow
it for one you have to allow it for all
and that's what it's gonna be and so you
know they can't really get mad at the
whole uh situation
so here is the the hill article that you
sent me trump election probe in georgia
to seat grand jury
um our special grand jury because i
guess this is a special grand jury right
i'm not going to read the whole thing
but the fulton county district authority
attorney fannie willis
has taken the unusual step of requesting
a special grand jury for the
investigation and the selection of that
panel begins monday now she is also
fannie willis has also famously said out
in public that if there are crimes that
he committed meaning trump and his
allies she will seek them out and she
will prosecute them through it i will
find you
that's essentially
sent the cnn article
cnn it's seen in politics
this is the this is the update on that
story which is basically talking about
how 23 people had been selected for the
special grand jury
and uh they're moving forward with it so
in other words so in other words the
news this morning that this was going to
happen and the news now is that it has
happened they have yeah it took about
two hours i guess of the process to
select the jurors and she's asked us to
the people of the state whether they
were available for service whether they
had
had a conflict uh if they said that
conflict you know they were ushered out
of the room but yeah it took about two
hours for them to get the 23 people they
needed and here we go
so we are the jury and the grand jury is
gonna hear the case rather donald trump
was trying to convince
state officials to commit election fraud
i believe that's kind of the
the the crux of the probe as it were
um is there i think there was some more
trending news some breaking news as we
were um also talking here
let's see
there was a warrant issued for the
alabama corrections officer okay
do you have do you have that link um
because someone was talking about that
earlier in the chat as well i believe
that something happened down in alabama
did you hear that there might be another
proud boy
um
uh possibly
uh turning on the
um
turning to be with the prosecution have
you heard that was that the uh was that
enrique turner yeah i know well i i'm
not sure there was my boy enrique tario
there was some news this morning about
it let's see this news story here
warrant issued for alabama corrections
officer on charges of permitting and
facilitating escape of missing inmate uh
so what is this story what what what's
going on here uh i have i have only read
like a blurb about it but basically that
she assisted in the escape of a an
officer and she had she's just like dude
no one can find her she's out on the run
so so is this kind of the same story
because they made a movie about uh
what state was it was up uh in the
northeast they they tried to get across
the canadian border you remember this
she helped you guys escape well it's not
a movie i mean they made a movie about
it but she was like she brought in
hacksaws for him brought in tools for
him
i don't know what movie this is what
does
anyone else know what this movie is
because uh clearly he's not making this
tony doesn't
of a female correction officer
helping two inmates escape from a prison
and they tried to get across the
canadian border they shot and killed one
of them and i can't remember maybe they
shot and killed the other one
[Music]
but this guy it says here casey white
was serving a 75-year sentence
for a series of crimes and was awaiting
a capital murder trial so this guy was
on trial for murder
and she helped him escape and now she's
on the run or he's on the run too are
you sure this isn't uh okay
well what i'm finding here is a lifetime
original movie
convicted killers david sweat and
richard matt seduce bored restless small
town mom joyce mitchell who aids and
abets there's uh audacious it's based on
a true story god damn it i'm just saying
man i'm not
come on look up the names
see here see here
cynthia's saying yeah she went to jail
it was in new york see i'm not making
this up okay well this story joyce
mitchell took place in new york
i don't know okay but this joyce
mitchell prison employee joyce mitchell
helps convicted murderers richard matt
and david sweat escape from the uh
clinton correctional facility in upstate
new york in 2015. see mj's even backing
me up here fences got me back i think
i'm reading you the story danny jamie's
got i'm not making ideas don't make [ __ ]
up that's mine but i'm telling you right
now according to this
uh it just says this sounds very similar
this vicky white thing sounds very
similar but it sounds like she's on the
run huh
uh yeah looks like she's out on uh on
the run
is it called
oh wait wait it's uh hold on what is
this
[Music]
that was my phone thinking i was talking
to it i wasn't well you know it i think
i think oh you know what it's called
escape from dannemora that's the other
one it's still about the same thing it's
based on this joyce mitchell story from
2015 clinton correctional facility in
upstate new york that's what it is but
you might have watched this escape from
dannemora but it's a series it looks
like
uh seven episode series there's also a
um
there was a movie i
think yeah there is one that's
new york prison break the seduction of
joyce mitchell you know i'm always i'm
always saying doubt me doubt me gabe
yeah but here's the thing i told you
what it was and you said that's not it
that's not what i'm talking about that's
not it and i would kept no you said a
lifetime lifetime yeah it's a lifetime
movie
it's like some kind of made up [ __ ] well
i mean i'm not making up [ __ ] i'm not
making enough
i don't make up stuff here i make sure
it's fully researched fully backed i do
my own research
that's why we're on the books of face
now and so we can do our own research uh
mobile check me bro yeah right
come at me with your facts [ __ ] come at
me with your facts gabe um so mo brooks
is trending too um i wonder if there's a
statement from mo brooks you think he'll
wear a bulletproof vest when he goes to
january 6. i think he always wears one
that's his excuse
like i'm just completely afraid i'm
terrified so i always get to wear blue
princess i mean you know in this country
it's not that bad of an idea to wear a
bulletproof vest i mean matt gatz were
one into marjory taylor green's hearings
probably i mean maybe he was terrified
he'd be arrested or something he had to
run i don't know what the hell is going
on i don't know what the hell is going
on um so let's i have some more video
that i want to show you guys um
here is here's the one gabe you're going
to love this oh do you know space force
you know space force we got this i've
heard of it heard of it yeah
and i think i showed this earlier but i
gotta show it again it's a show on
netflix but it just got canceled no no
it's actually
trump started the space wars you know
we're gonna we're gonna conquer the the
space and the force and the i don't know
it's really dumb it's like he thought he
would be responsible for the real star
trek or some [ __ ] but listen to what he
was listen what he says what planet
we're gonna go to listen here gabe we'll
land the first woman on the moon yeah
the united states will be the first hey
that sounds all right landing the first
women on the moon i don't think that's a
bad deal i don't think that's a bad deal
yeah i mean i'm not exactly you know
you know wanting to send people into
space like
it really is dumb you know like jeff
bezos and all these guys want to go in
their space dildos but you know okay
well let's but let's listen what planet
he wants to inhabit here nation to land
an astronaut on ours
did you catch it he wants to land an
astronaut on nars
and an astronaut on ours on nars on nars
yeah you've heard of this planet haven't
you
you know what we should try to do we
should try to get neil degrasse tyson on
here yeah to try to figure out where
this [ __ ] planet in ours is at right
yeah can you explain you know when i
hear nars i think of uh
uh pinky in the brain yeah and when he'd
be like
like that's what like when i hear nars i
just think of the the phrase like it's
just like a like a like a just yeah he
was like like that was his thing and
that's what he did on the show
uh but nars i would love to learn what
planet that is that's cool i i think we
should maybe you know what maybe that's
where jd uh mandela's
maybe that's where he's from maybe he's
a nurse maybe he's a narcian right he's
a narcian from nars yeah and that's why
he's endorsing him for the ohio state
which is weird because technically he
would be an illegal alien according to
trump in his own words
so it seems weird that he would kind of
endorse a man that was uh not a us
citizen you know well it happens here's
here's uh a visual of what
what donald trump really had to go
through
this
jd vance or excuse me jd mandel or josh
vance which is it which is it i'm just
pointing that out the same guy who
thinks there's a planet nars right
whoosh now clearly you're like what is
it what is the other it's like you know
uh
women are from mars and men or
men are from mars and women are from
venus right so like men are from nars so
it's maybe trump supporting men are from
nars right mars
the libtards the [ __ ] lib males the the
snowflakes the cucks they're from
mars the real tough guys you know who
have to wear bulletproof vests sounds
sounds kind of toxic
yeah well that happens it happens uh
speaking of toxic um rachel bittikover
has a graphic and i think it's been
circulating or circulating around
twitter now folks i'm going to show you
this graphic and i want you to be very
wary of this graphic i'm not excited
that this graphics going around but it's
going around so i'm going to show you
and the reason why is because we don't
look away here um
this poll is claiming now this is a
washington post abc poll this poll is
claiming that the
generic ballot is sinking for
republicans now you have heard us talk
about the generic ballot a lot on this
show with dr rachel bittikoffer she's
one of the best political strategists i
believe in this country that we have on
our side and our side being
pro-democracy um and i i actually text
rachel this morning i said hey here's
this graphic it's circling around i
think this is a bad thing we should not
be circulating this around but it's
happening anyway so we got to hit it
head on folks here's the thing here's
what i think this this is uh going to do
if we believe this [ __ ] on this on this
graphic now this may be the truth it may
not be the truth but we cannot act like
this is the full-blown truth gonna be
the truth nothing but the truth and we
don't have to do anything about it i
wouldn't trust it
the only the only thing we need to make
sure that we do
is that we make this the truth folks
um and what we have to do is keep the
fight for the for pro-democracy we have
to fight for our democracy at the ballot
box in our election and in our messaging
this clearly is an indicator if this is
true which i i would be very skeptical
of it if it's true or not
but if it is true it is because they are
the party of crazy and people are
peeling away from the crazy um for
instance some of these local school
board races gabe have you seen some of
these stories about these crt voodooists
oh yeah doing honors they're losing big
time in these
in these local races and generally in a
local school board race the people that
are engaged are the people who are
engaged no matter what election it is
right um which is a very good indication
of people who probably would vote in a
midterm election like we're going to
have this fall so all this is good
indications but we cannot we cannot
spike the ball
now
we cannot spike the ball now now that
this is a victory we have to we have to
act like this this graphic here
might be and probably is a hundred
percent [ __ ] and we have to keep the
fire going we have to keep it burning i
mean i i look at this right now and i
say
that's great you know hopefully that is
true however this is those moments where
you look at me like oh cool cool i could
put the i could put the the foot off the
the gas you know and i can like kind of
let things coast right like no i'm not
going to let the muscle atrophy i'm
going to keep working it out this is the
moment when you know to use another kind
of sports related thing it's like when
you're running a race and you're like
there is no one around me that i can see
in my peripherals right and so i'm gonna
like just kind of like let it off i'll
just coast it through and then you've
got someone who just like and runs right
past you because you decided to not give
it your all and run right through the
finish line ticker tape right so like i
look at that and i and i say like this
is great right it's it's potentially a
movement in the right direction however
i don't want to take it as the absolute
truth because
we've seen it before you look at 2016
and you look at what was happening with
hillary and everyone thought it was a
sure shot because trump was a [ __ ]
lunatic right he was a racist bigoted
misogynistic idiot and people like
there's no way he can win
and then of course the polling was wrong
and he became the president for four
years and we entered into an absolute
[ __ ] show of a country and now i look at
this and i'm like this is a great signal
in the right direction but i i feel
weary
and not all the way confident to say
like it's a done deal because again this
is only 46 to 45. right and what's the
margin of error here i have no idea well
even even if the margin of error is a
little bit here the only thing that this
means is we're still neck and neck oh
totally we can't stop we got to keep
going with this pro-democracy message we
keep out the pounding that these people
want to take away your liberty and not
because it's untrue it is the truth they
will take away their liberty they want a
sexualized kid's gender they want to
marry children jesus christ yesterday's
nazi q anon rally was in nebraska to
[ __ ] so trump could stump for a
goddamn a molester right herbster i
think his name is is this this guy that
this roy moore want to be is that who
this guy is this guy running for
governor they were stumping for a
goddamn sexual assaulter
the entire group of people who went
there to cheer him on and all the
politicians and all the [ __ ] idiots
that went they were supporting this
guy's candidacy as governor this grabber
in chief in nebraska as it were i mean
when they say when they say be an ally
it's not be an ally to a sexual assault
predator like that's not what it means
right like and that's what trump is
right because i guess you know birds of
a feather they [ __ ]
creep together like i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is
right exactly and that's and i look at
this right now and yeah 46 45 that's
great that 46 is above 45 but [ __ ] man
this guy's changed this may change next
week where it becomes 47 43 or like you
know whatever it might be and i and i'm
i'm weary i am very weary and skeptical
to look at polls now you know uh
especially with people [ __ ] you know
nate silver out in the world that are
conducting them but i look at this and i
say
it's time well
we are six months away six months away
rachel says here rachel says it's time
to turn up the heat now
now is the time to really press these
[ __ ] now when now it's clear
that it is moving in our direction it is
moving in the pro-democracy people's
direction it is time to punch the gas
not to pump the brakes so remember that
out there all you pro-democracy people
don't stop talking to your community
members don't stop asking the questions
like we opposed here
when you go out to your community you
say did you hear that florida
republicans are trying to ban math
that's a good place to start and i know
it feels like oh well tony that that
seems crazy but i'm telling you right
there
that is a good place to start yeah um we
got some news it looks like and
everyone's pointing it out uh let me go
see if i can uh get on my profile i
think i retweeted this while we were
talking here and uh let's see joe one of
our favorite jojo from jurors she tweets
here breaking it's a tremendous [ __ ] you
to trump rudy giuliani will testify
before the january sixth committee yeah
well i mean here's the thing it was two
weeks ago
when he when it was revealed that rudy
giuliani was was on he unlocked the
remaining phones willingly
right
and you're talking about the phones that
they actually got in the raid um
for the ukraine uh debacle
the right exactly why the cheeto dust
monster was impeached the first time and
you look at this and
and and you see you see rudy giuliani is
willingly
willingly
uh cooperating with the feds on the
ukraine situation right because there
was the raid that happened last year
right and they
they said oh we had like what 18
different devices were were
taken from his place and you know some
of them they were able to access and
some of them were locked and it wasn't
until just a couple weeks ago did he
unlock them himself to give them access
to say like hey listen you can download
scrape and take whatever you want from
the phone
so
for me i look at that and i'm like
broody is now on the
the attempted train of redemption here
right he is trying to rewrite his role
in the history despite the fact that he
was a conspirator right-hand man was
working with trump was was spearheading
the the uh
the legal side
of protesting the 2020 election and not
only that not only that he was in the
war room not with steve bannon with
christina bob with the oath keepers with
the proud boys he was right there with
him and he was in the war room so if
anything was being said in that war room
between steve bannon and christina bob
which i think a lot of people discount
christina bob her they think she's some
kind of oan reporter she used to be a
[ __ ] high level uh
official at dhs she's a lawyer she's a
former firmer jag lawyer um she was
she's career military this this lady is
not just some dumb oan reporter she was
in that room and she was helping plan
with steve bannon and rudy giuliani and
that is that is the [ __ ] most
important part here is that rudy
giuliani was sitting there for all this
conversation now rather the guy will be
able to fart him out or not you know i
don't know um you know i and i don't
make them mean to make light of the rudy
giuliani story going on but i found this
video and it's i guess he's pimping his
cameo we gotta watch this
holy [ __ ]
they it's hard for them
to let us make jokes of them when they
make them of themselves let's watch
i'm rudy giuliani
if you want to have a really nice
conversation
or a birthday greeting
or just talk golf
go to the link below
what what the [ __ ]
i don't know where is he golfing okay i
want to know right is he in florida is
he at mar-a-lago seems a little weird
but who knows
you know what's crazy about this oh god
the craziest part is that trump is
really like he's hanging by a thread
here and this is the guy
this is the guy right here i'm going to
turn the sound off on this but this is
the guy that he's relying on here to
save his ass
right here 2020 election was rigged it's
all a fraud
joe biden isn't the president it's
actually trump and meanwhile he's just
swinging his arms and i'm you know what
i have a feeling like that was the same
[ __ ] he did in court and he's like your
honor you don't understand it was stolen
it was stolen and they're like uh mr
giuliani can you please stop swinging
your arms he's like you don't get it it
was rigged it was stolen he's like i
farted and i gave someone coded like
that's you know
i mean really really he he he he is
grifting here with the cameo because the
guy's broke because the guy he's gonna
go testify against did not pay his
[ __ ] legal bills this is you can't he
also said remember he said he has
insurance
so i don't know if that insurance is
going to come said he had insurance rudy
giuliani what do you mean insurance like
he bought a policy
he's got receipts kind of he's got
receipts
remember he said he there was i forgot
when that was last year but he said that
he had he had insurance he had he had
receipts of things that happened
remember he's been in these rooms he's
been oh [ __ ] they're on to me oh well
if anyone can hear that if anyone hear
the cops uh but what but rudy giuliani
was the one who said that he had
insurance
um and he had the receipts he was there
in all these situations like he could
tie different people together
and different things that were said
and he was privy to information and
conversations that were had up before
january 6th during and after so
well clearly clearly his statements even
today this is three hours ago this is
rudy giuliani's twitter account from
three hours ago he said if you want
george soros pro criminal manhattan d.a
alvin bragg removed from office on
january 1st 2023
vote for andrew giuliani this is his son
his [ __ ] son who can't run a camera
um trying to run for office he's the
only one who can
really fight crime and win support to
donate so he's calling alvin bragg the
george soros pro criminal manhattan now
here's the thing
if he is if
if alan bragg is pro-criminal then it
means the criminals that he's not
prosecuting are you
yeah you and your your [ __ ] cheeto
dust mobster your mango mussolini jesus
and what is the george soros thing why
did is that just a buzzword they do that
to us too
what is it i think i i honestly they i
think that they look at george soros and
they're like oh socialism
uh money right democrats
and
they use it as an attempt of like oh we
got you so good with the george soros
burned oh you so good man you know we go
you're so good and it's like no you
didn't like what you what are they going
to do
what are they going to do when that old
sack
dies because george soros is like 196
and he's looking really old
george soros yeah he's pretty old he's
hey he's old he's really old what are
they gonna do when he dies like what
kind of [ __ ] are they gonna make up
george soros was born in 1930 he's 91
years old
um speaking of uh
crazy stuff gosh look at these alerts i
know um
robin's pointing out which i've talked
about this before
and
the the word is is that christina bob
the eastman memo um the the plan for the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup she was
actually the one who wrote that memo
and it was instituted by eastman and we
now know
we now know that a judge out in
california federal judge believes that
there's crimes committed between eastman
and trump to plot to overturn and
obstruct an official proceeding that's
why he did not allow them to claim
attorney-client privilege with some of
those emails there was a lot of emails a
few of them he did not let them claim
that
um which maybe rudy giuliani's testimony
today standing in the room with john
eastman with with steve bannon and with
christina bob
maybe maybe maybe maybe we we will get
the answers as the american public
because that's what the january 6 select
committee is designed to do here is to
get us the american people the actual
truth not what the true social wants to
tell us is the truth um so that's some
more breaking news uh let's see what
else do we have today did you know today
is teacher appreciation week do you know
that today is dwayne the rock johnson's
birthday was it really happy birthday
happy birthday but no uh i did not know
that today was teacher appreciation week
week week it is when it should be much
longer than that yeah like a whole
school year like you should have yeah
yeah it'd be great to pay them more yeah
you know you know give them decent
benefits make sure they have a good
especially because they have to deal
with all that [ __ ] from the parents who
are like
you know and [ __ ] school board
meetings and them right doing the mask
and having to having to work out of
their homes to teach the children remote
learning like that's not easy right
that's that's pretty taxing on you as a
person to bring you your own work life
and that much stress into your home life
like
you know but i will say that um
go ahead go ahead no i was just gonna
say that i feel like it's one of those
things where like we don't pay them
enough we don't give them enough
benefits right and it's something that
where it's like should definitely be
more than a week of appreciation it
should be you know
the whole [ __ ] school year right or
the whole year right because they're
working during they're working during
their summer break to bring kids uh and
help them during the summer for people
who need um you know uh
work to
to get ready for the next school year or
they have to uh you know work on classes
that they didn't pass or whatever like
at the end of the day like it should be
a whole [ __ ] year what it is
well i think so we have some more
breaking news here um here is um
the new york
police department veteran uh veteran of
nypd has become the first person
convicted of assaulting a police officer
during the u.s capitol riot the federal
jury now this is in the jury trial
rejected thomas webster's claim that he
acted in self-defense when he tackled
the police officer and grabbed his face
mask i believe this is a picture of the
guy right here with the with the flag
um so he is uh it looks like he is
convicted i'm not sure
what the uh oh yeah i saw that yeah yeah
what's what's the link you sent me here
that one is a video that uh i we just
got from uh minus margie over here okay
which is uh the insurance that i was
referring to she's got the video so i
just sent the video to you okay let's uh
let's pull up you're ready uh if i can
you're ready is that yeah yeah it's an
ad that's not
[Music]
very opposite of alex jones you're ready
you know it's like you're ready you're
ready now this is a three minute video
let's uh let's take a look here let's
see if we can pull this
up there we go
let's listen to us
being repeatedly asked what happens if
his top client throws him quote under
the bus giuliani raising eyebrows with
his answers saying he has insurance and
just tonight abc news learning the house
intelligence committee has obtained
video and audio from one of giuliani's
indicted associates abc's david wright
at the white house
this weekend do we have
fox news does this video show rudy
giuliani saying the thing about the uh
the insurance
i believe
here it is maybe ukraine i've seen
things written like he's going to throw
me under the bus right when they say
that i say he isn't but i have insurance
so there it is there's the question i
told you i'm not making [ __ ] up just
like you weren't making [ __ ] up about
that lifetime movie i didn't i'm not
saying i just wanted to know if it was
like an insurance policy or like
receipts i mean it was just
it was
his insurance policy on his own life is
right this is all mob talk right like
this is the and this is the craziest
part about all these [ __ ] trump
sycophants they're like oh we're against
criminals and we want to lock criminals
up right and they're that's all they're
doing is talking like yeah i mean you
you know if
you know him really well when like he's
like i'm the mayor and i cleaned up
cities like well i guess he had to be
one to no one right right well i mean it
happens sometimes that way um
apparently um oh we're in week three of
the johnny depp
trial are you still on are you still on
team amber heard on this one
we haven't done much
i've never been on team amber heard oh
really well yeah well i thought you were
i thought you were no no no no no
i will say the whole situation is really
[ __ ] up but i'm i'm
like it's okay so i haven't been
following i haven't i haven't been so
[ __ ] up i mean i haven't i've watched
i've watched some clips this weekend
because they just keep they keep
recommending them to me on youtube so
i'm i ha i don't watch the trial i watch
the clips afterward when i so give us a
synopsis of what you found of the amber
church because we only got five minutes
left
trial yeah the amber turd yeah
tell us tell us what you make of it
since you're not since you're not on
team amber anymore you're not anymore i
wasn't here i thought you were worried
i'm not on team amber i mean okay okay
okay i mean i've been hearing stories
maybe maybe like on on set and stuff
like even jason momoa is not a big fan
of her but has to work with her they try
to get her off of aquaman too
um but because that's kind of what she's
famous for is that the awkward right
exactly yeah but there's a lot to really
you know johnny jeff being like oh you
know i gave her her i gave her her shot
i helped her out i coached her here and
there and then you know then they were
like trying to
they brought in random people to try to
uh to make the case against him right
and you know they brought in a
psychologist they brought in other
experts to try to use a her a bodyguard
to to go against him i mean like it's
it's very laughable like a lot of the
stuff is like johnny depp being like
[ __ ] man like what are you guys talking
about this is not what i said this is a
like these are you know these are uh
newspapers spreading um
you know misinformation about me like
there is it's it's a whole mess it's a
whole just [ __ ] big mess
um i don't think she's as innocent as
she says
and i think that he also
is a victim of abuse in the relationship
and a lot of people like oh well why you
know why didn't he leave right it's the
same reason why you ask a woman why
didn't she leave like you can't victim
blame anyone for the situation but
the whole thing
they're making it very public i don't
know if that's the actual way it should
be done you know or or if he really
needs this so he's like listen i don't
want all to be on court documents i want
people to actually see it being talked
about and mentioned and questioned
and so yeah well maybe maybe maybe we'll
do a little more commentary on this yeah
i mean if you want to we can another day
if people want to watch clips we can
watch clips and just yeah we can on some
clips of this and maybe maybe we'll
maybe we'll go through this three weeks
of this trial we'll pick out the best
funniest clips and and clown these guys
because i really i mean truly from what
i've seen it seems like johnny depp's is
just trying to clear his name here yeah
is what he's trying to do that maybe all
these lies were told told about him
maybe they weren't i don't know i think
that's what the defamation suits about
that she was telling lies about him to
ruin his career so i mean maybe maybe
he'll clear his name here i don't know
if they'll actually you know the other
crazy thing is that the future owner of
twitter i'm sorry the current owner of
twitter right elon musk
amber heard did he really oh yeah that's
interesting that's interesting maybe we
can tie it into the elon story uh one
more story before we go uh i don't know
if you guys see what the former is the
former trump as defense secretary mark
esper is writing a book believe it or
not gabe he's gonna do a tell-all book
where he's gonna probably boy
um but in this book
tennessee holler is um is reporting here
trump wanted to shoot protesters is what
the former defense secretary says
in the book um he tells stuff that would
be great to know at the time he tells us
trump said can you can't you shoot them
just shoot them in the legs or something
so that's where the shoot him in the leg
thing is coming from today
so
um if you see any tweets about getting
shot in the leg it's probably because
trump wanted to shoot protesters
you know uh i i guess i guess he is um
he's now he's now against ashley babbitt
being shot i don't know i can't tell
anymore i can't tell you know she was
just a tourist
who got shot for breaking the law and
um
not
not adhering to a stand-down uh rule she
was she was a traitor she was an
insurrectionist why didn't you just
comply
right right right uh anyways so that is
that is to round up
and to wrap up
the new the news
i feel like we should have the the guy
who does the intro we should have a new
one that's like ladies and gentlemen
maybe maybe
you know like he should do like a let's
get ready to rumble kind of thing for
the moment that in which it does become
wrestlemania just full on wrestlemania
because we are we are like right there
i'm sure alex jones could use some cash
maybe we pay him to do our
our intro does he do cameos i don't know
i don't know maybe we can check that out
he might i mean rudy giuliani is doing
cameos i don't know man i'm uh i'm on
cameo but i haven't officially like made
my page public oh so you can't you can't
okay you want to make cameos hey if you
want to do a cameo
i'll say happy birthday or just chat
with what the [ __ ] does that mean okay
well i don't know grandpa farty mcsharty
rudy giuliani making the news today
because he is testifying
before the january 6 elect committing
the select committee
looks like they're going to get members
of congress's data whether they like it
or not maybe they're asking now
remember to tune in tomorrow we'll have
more breaking news i'm sure right here
on the tony michael's podcast noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch make sure to
subscribe on the youtube channel do not
miss a thing
and also on the midas touch facebook
page so if you're on the books of face
remember click that link at the top to
subscribe to the youtube channel so you
don't miss anything
until tomorrow at noon eastern
11th central nine pacific surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time